foreign
[Music]
welcome to the stage vice president and
general manager computer and machine
learning infrastructure mark lowmeyer
[Music]
all right uh hello everyone it's really
great to be here in person today with
all of you thanks everyone for joining
my name is Mark lowmeyer and I lead the
compute and machine learning
infrastructure product team at Google
cloud and I'm really really excited
today to be able to share more with you
about all the amazing products we've
been building and how they can help you
achieve your goals uh later in this
session my colleague Sachin Gupta will
share the latest on our storage
networking and distributed Cloud
products
so at Google we always start with the
customer and so let's start today with
what we're hearing from all of you you
know our customers are telling us they
want to enable and accelerate their
overall companies business
transformation
and at the heart of this are really the
applications that support and Empower
your customers and enable your employees
and if you look across this application
portfolio many customers have hundreds
or in some cases thousands of
applications but they generally fall
into these three big categories
first virtually everyone sees the
transformational opportunity that's
available with generative AI
but if you look at it most customers are
really in the early stages of figuring
out where to start
second customers are looking to rapidly
build new modern applications leveraging
everything the cloud has to offer
and third last not not least let's not
forget those traditional Enterprise
applications which for many of our
customers represent the vast majority of
their workloads you want to make sure
those applications can really continue
to thrive
and as it leaders you have to enable all
of this while your core responsibilities
are becoming even more complex you have
to maintain reliability and security at
higher scale and under new threats you
have to reduce operational complexity
while hiring and retaining a world-class
team
and you have to meet aggressive
sustainability goals
so as we look across these it's really
clear to us that the old approaches are
not going to meet the new challenges
ahead
we've never be seen before the kinds of
Demands that these new workloads are
placing on the infrastructure and while
this is true across all types of
workloads probably the best example of
this is AI so if you look at this chart
here it's showing the growth and the
size of the number of parameters in
large language models over the last five
years
and they're increasing in size by 10x
per year so that's 10 to the fifth over
5 years which is a lot of zeros for
those of you who are counting so
unfortunately we can no longer just
throw more general purpose Hardware at
this problem and one of the reasons why
is that the benefits of Moore's Law are
slowing down
so for example while transistor count is
still doubling every two years it's not
doing so at a fixed cost and Power
so as a result it's really clear what's
worked for us in the past is not going
to be able to prepare us for the future
we need a more intentional approach to
Cloud infrastructure
so let's talk about how we're responding
to this at Google
so our strategy here is centered around
a concept that we call workload
optimized infrastructure and the core
idea is to look at literally each and
every workload and then design and
optimize at a systems level across
compute storage and networking hardware
and and across software as well to meet
the unique needs of each and every
workload and as a result we can deliver
breakthrough gains on the outcomes that
our customers care about and need for
those workloads across performance
reliability security cost and
sustainability
now anyone can say these words right
easy to say but what enables Google to
actually deliver is our engineering
excellence and platform level innovation
So within this there are really four
main areas to set us apart first at the
heart of the platform is our deep
silicon and Systems Innovation such as
our tpus our offloads Optical switches
and more that I'll share today
second we're also open and ecosystem
friendly embracing Partners across
Hardware platforms such as Intel AMD and
Nvidia and a broad range of Open Source
and software partners
third we continue to expand our planet
skill footprint leveraging scalable
distributed systems and then finally our
infrastructure is AI driven and
automated to help Empower your teams to
do more as you saw in the earlier
keynote yesterday with duet AI
so this is sort of the high level
background now let's get into how this
is resulting in concrete benefits for
each workload type and let's start with
our favorite AI workloads
so you know here we're really really
fortunate to be able to work with
thousands of customers across many
Industries and verticals to help them
leverage AI to transform their business
the customers that are the most
sophisticated and the most knowledgeable
in the space are choosing Google because
AI is in our DNA so let me share more
from startups to Enterprises customers
choose Google Cloud for AI because of
our deep expertise across all the
relevant domains of course it starts
with industry defining research in fact
the original Transformers paper which is
the foundation for the llms taking the
World by storm today came from Google
research
then we channel that research into
Cutting Edge models such as pom2 and
many many more that you heard about
yesterday
but it's not just about our models it's
also about as I mentioned before
embracing the ecosystem and open source
and Google is a really great partner and
significant contributor here
however the models by themselves are not
enough you also need to know how to
scale them in production and at Google
we have unique experience running
running many apps that serve literally
billions of users each
uh and to do all of this you of course
need to build on the best infrastructure
so now let's dig into our AI optimized
infrastructure next
um at Google we're building the
industry's most complete and most
advanced AI Cloud platform for more than
a decade we've been perfecting an
integrated system that's designed for AI
workloads
it's designed to meet the needs of each
and every AI workload and every customer
and user type from model Builders to
Providers to Consumers
working from the bottom up it starts
with our leading TPU and GPU accelerated
Computing options complemented by a
range of AI optimized storage and data
integration options
we bring these together into a super
Computing system with scalable
networking offloads water cooled systems
and more
and we make it really easy to consume
with support for both GCE and gke
and finally we deliver unique value and
software enabling training and serving
of workloads across multiple systems
complemented by open Frameworks high
performance compilers and more
finally with vertex AI we make it easy
to integrate and serve Google models and
our partners ecosystem models in your
applications
So Yesterday Thomas announced the
expansion of our TPU portfolio with TPU
v5e so let me go deeper here now
so given the massive demand that we're
seeing for AI optimized infrastructure
we wanted to make tpus even more
accessible to a broader range of
customers and use cases
with TPU v5e we've made major strides in
efficiency with up to 2x better training
performance per dollar versus TPU V4 and
two and a half times better inference
performance per dollar
we've also made them more versatile
including eight flexible VM shapes that
serve our customers diverse workload
sizes across training tuning and serving
and finally through the magic of
hardware and software working together
we've enabled these smaller systems to
scale some of the largest workloads with
technologies that enable a single
workload to span multiple clusters
scaling to tens of thousands of these
chips
all right so now for a real treat we're
actually going to show you uh this AI
optimized Cloud infrastructure for the
first time to the general public so with
that let's uh let's cue the video
foreign
applications are powered by something
you almost never get to see
purpose-built AI infrastructure and
while we're operating this
infrastructure Planet scale it all
starts with the chip Google's tensor
processing units or tpus are custom
developed application specific
integrated circuits designed to create
Ed scale supercomputers that handle some
of the world's largest AI workloads the
real magic happens when these chips are
all interconnected using our custom
intercore Optical interconnect to create
a single super computer capable of
utilizing thousands of these chips to
handle some of the world's largest
inference and training workflows
realizing the power of our data center
networking we can create large scale
versions of such super computers
consisting of hundreds of thousands of
interconnected chips Google has taken a
step further and utilized Optical
circuit switch technology that allows
the super computers to reconfigure
themselves and create efficient machine
shapes and sizes this is all made
possible by our state-of-the-art OCS
software infrastructure optimized for
efficiency and speed
our vertical power delivered to the
super computers is pulled by our latest
generation water cooling system that is
designed with sustainability in mind all
this technology has the attention of our
dedicated team of data center
technicians and security personnel there
to guide through our various security
protocols all of this operating at the
scale of our entire planet because we
believe that AI is for everyone
thank you
all right so that was awesome as a
hardware geek I think there's nothing
nothing cooler than checking out the
hardware behind all these systems you
know but if you think about it it's not
just about the hardware equally
important is the software on top of this
Hardware that enables our customers to
make the AI development smooth and cost
effective
so here first we're really excited to
announce first class support for pytorch
for tpus
pytorch is an incredibly popular
framework for AI developers and now they
can leverage the benefits of tpus in
these pytorch environments
second we're making it easy to
efficiently scale model training and
serving across physically disparate
clusters with multi-slice training and
multi-host inferencing
third we're making it easy to
orchestrate AI workloads with GK support
and streamline data integration tuning
and application development with vertex
AI
as a result leading AI innovators like
anthropic are seeing significant
benefits from TPU v5e as they build the
next wave of AI on Google Cloud
and we're really looking forward to
enabling the broader industry with these
amazing TPU capabilities now and in the
future
so tpus are great but we're also
partnering and investing to offer the
best cloud for gpus as well you heard
from Thomas and Jensen about our deep
partnership and capabilities we're
delivering here together so again let me
go a little bit deeper here now
a few months ago we introduced our new
G2 VM based on the Nvidia L4 GPU
Google Cloud was the first and still the
only leading cloud provider to offer the
service to customers
G2 is great for lower for a lower price
of entry with two to four times better
performance compared to Prior generation
Nvidia T4 gpus
G4 excels for cost-effective Gen AI use
cases and other use cases such as
virtual workstation or digital twin
simulations
and as a result of this value we're
seeing rapid adoption across many
leading customers that you see here
next as you heard earlier we're also
really excited to introduce the general
availability of our A3 VMS coming next
month
A3 is based on the Nvidia h100 GPU and
it's purpose built to train and serve
incredibly demanding AI models and llms
A3 leverages Google's leading networking
Technologies to provide massive scale
and performance including our custom
designed IQs offloading the host and it
integrates with our data center network
with reconfigurable Optical links that
can adjust the topology on demand
A3 is a leap in super Computing
capabilities over prior generations with
three times faster training
A3 is also able to operate at scale
scaling to tens of thousands of h100
gpus
finally A3 is fully supported through
GCE gke and vertex AI offering a wide
range of choices for AI researchers
developers and operators
so across gpus and tpus we are
innovating at a systems level to give
customers the strong Foundation they
need to build generative AI services
that will transform their business
but uh don't just take it from me let's
go to video again to hear directly from
a leading gen AI innovator character AI
about their experience
one of the founding Engineers the
character AI character AI is a full
stack uh directed consumer
social AI platform technically speaking
we'll need to make our entire stack more
scalable everything from bringing on
more accelerators to power the language
model to improving the back-end systems
we host all of our product
infrastructure on Google Cloud
increasingly using Google's accelerators
gpus and tpus
these are the lifeblood of our product
so on Google Cloud we can
experiment and find what is the right
platform for a particular workload it's
great to have that flexibility to choose
which products and solutions are most
valuable so yeah big fans of Google
Cloud
all right that is that is so cool by the
way if you haven't tried it yet I would
highly recommend you check out character
AI it's a really really uh cool and
interesting service
all right
um so a lot of innovation in our AI
optimized infrastructure but of course
you also have a lot of other types of
workloads that are really powering your
business so now let me share more about
what's new for Enterprise workloads our
customers here have a broad range so
we've optimized our VM families for all
of these workload types ranging from
common web applications to demanding
databases such as sap Hana
so here let me share some exciting
updates on the new products that we're
introducing just a few months ago we did
our new c3vm Google was the first to
Market with VMS based on the fourth
generation Intel Sapphire Rapids
processor which also leverages our
offload Technologies and provides up to
35 percent better performance versus
comparable generation VMS with a
consistent performance and great
maintenance experience
now we're really really pleased to
announce we're extending the C family to
both AMD and arm processors
we're announcing the new c3d VM based on
amd's fourth generation epic processor
C3 dvms offer up to 45 performance
improvement over the prior generation
AMD VMS for workloads such as postgres
MySQL redis and many more
finally we're also really excited to
pre-announce the preview of c3a our
newest arm-based VM it offers up to 40
percent Better Price performance than
comparable x86 VMS for a very very cost
effective solution
in addition we're also focused on
enabling leading solutions for high
performance Computing across Industries
such as Financial Services engineering
design and more
in support of this we recently announced
our new H3 VMS purpose built for HPC
workloads
with full core performance and 200
gigabits per second networking H3
outperforms the prior generation C2 VMS
by up to three times across a broad
range of HPC workloads
in addition we're really pleased to
partner with a broad range of HPC
focused ecosystem Partners like Altera
to help our customers realize the full
benefits of these amazing Technologies
so these are some really great options
for compute but many Enterprise
workloads also require block storage
and here we offer a wide range of
options to support our customers iops
and throughputs needs
to meet these needs last year we
introduced hyperdisc and Enterprise
class block storage service
hyperdisc fundamentally decouples
compute from Storage much like a private
Cloud San but with all the elasticity
scalability and economic benefits of a
cloud service enables you to dynamically
tune the storage to the new unique needs
of each workload and it's built to scale
so today I'm really really pleased to
announce major major advances for
hyperdisc first I'm excited to announce
the preview of hyperdisc extreme with
500 000 iops which is the fastest among
hyperscalers
second the new hyperdisc balance is in
preview next month it's really ideal for
generous general purpose workloads and
it delivers 2 to 10 times better
performance than comparable offers
finally to complete the family hyperdisc
throughput is now GA and provides fast
cost effective block storage for
throughput Hungry workloads such as data
analytics
so that's all great but I'm even more
excited to introduce a new capability
here called hyperdisc storage pools now
Cloud up Cloud cost optimization is top
of mind for many of you as I've spoken
with you and within this storage has
traditionally been one of the biggest
culprits of cloud spend
and why is that well discs are often
tied to individual VMS and therefore not
optimally utilized on-prem you use a
sand storage pool to address this but in
the cloud such pools have not really
been available so far
so we're changing this today with
hyperdisc storage pools in preview
these storage pools can be shared across
your workloads simplifying management
and driving higher utilization
so by combining the benefits of a single
storage capacity pool with thin
provisioning compression deduplication
and other Technologies we can reduce the
TCO for workloads like databases by up
to 40 percent
really really amazing
so now let's jump to another workload
and one of the most common Enterprise
workloads and one I happen to know
pretty well everything running in
vsphere on-prem
so with Google Cloud VMware engine you
can simply bring your vsphere based
workloads to Google and will manage the
infrastructure for you with great
availability and performance
today we're announcing the next stage of
innovation with gcbe
first our new node type ve2 with two
terabytes of RAM and flexible and
powerful vcpu and storage configurations
second we're adding three new external
storage options support for NetApp
volumes support for Google file store
our own file system and support for vsan
storage only nodes you'll hear more
about these later
with these new options we're making an
even more cost effective to run a broad
range of vsphere-based workloads in
Google Cloud
in fact one customer liq was able to
significantly increase their application
availability reduce incidents and save
60 percent in total cost of ownership by
migrating from on-prem to gcve truly
truly amazing
more broadly we know you also want to
achieve better reliability in the cloud
than anywhere else and while multi-az
available slas are great many Enterprise
workloads also care deeply about the VM
level SLA so I'm really delighted to
announce a new and improved three nines
uptime SLA for all single instance VMS
in Google Cloud
and for memory optimized VMS that are
used for demanding workloads like sap
Hana and others we're going even further
to offer three and a half nine single
instance SLA which is the highest among
other leading cloud hyperscalers
together coupled with our ability to do
non-disruptive maintenance using live
migration this really makes Google Cloud
ideal for Mission critical Enterprise
workloads
so I hope you're all as excited about
these new product announcements as I am
and to uh to wrap it up I'd like to
share finally an inside look at one of
the key Technology Building Blocks that
really enables many of these new
products you heard about it in Thomas's
keynote and we call this Google Cloud
titanium this is a Next Generation
tiered offload technology stack
so let me give a little context here you
know if you go back in time in the cloud
right initially the host CPU handles it
all at all around the workloads around
the virtualization software stack
storage I O Network processing
everything was running on that host CPU
then the cloud industry Advanced by
offloading some of those infrastructure
operations onto smartnics
this delivered really significant gains
it was fantastic
however ultimately the performance and
scale was still bound to that host since
the smart Knicks are running in those
hosts
so as we at Google thought about what
the future of workloads would require we
knew we needed to be able to scale
Beyond The Host
so we're really really pleased to
introduce Google Cloud titanium which is
a Next Generation tiered offload
architecture providing breakthrough
scale performance and security that you
need for the future of cloud workloads
to do this we are leveraging and
extending our distributed Planet scale
infrastructure services
effectively we can move many of the
storage networking security and other
operations completely off the host and
run them as processes as a scale out
service in the cloud
this enables us to for example deliver
the 500 000 iops for hyperdisc extreme
that I talked about before and we can
provide this even to very small VMS on
the host
so this is a really really fundamental
architecture capability that you're
going to see us leverage more and more
to deliver on our workload optimized
infrastructure vision
all right so I hope you enjoyed this
view into our strategy for workload
optimized infrastructure and how we're
applying that to deliver amazing
products for all of your workloads now
to share what's new with cloud storage
networking and our distributed cloud my
colleague Sachin Gupta will join us now
welcome Sachin
thank you
thanks Mark and hi everyone I'm Sachin
Gupta and I lead the infrastructure and
solutions group here at Google Cloud
now I'm super excited to tell you more
about how customers are innovating with
all the great new products that our
teams have built
earlier Mark talked about the tremendous
innovation in gpus and tpus for AI
workloads from model training to tuning
to serving
all of this is made possible because of
a foundation of Highly reliable and
performance Storage Solutions
as you know it takes petabytes or more
of data to build and train AI models and
many of those applications leverage
existing Frameworks like Pi torch and
tensorflow which often run on file
systems
but many of you want to Leverage The
scalability the performance and the
affordability of object storage
if you try this on your own it can be a
complex task it requires custom code
and that's why we introduced cloud
storage fuse
it's a fully managed file system that
allows you to easily run applications
that are expecting file systems but on
top of the scalable and performant
Google Cloud Storage
and with the power of gke and Jai
integration and simple file system
access
codeway scale their gen AI Avatar app to
hundreds of millions of users in simply
a matter of weeks
we've also heard the need for ultra low
latency and terabyte per second file
systems to accelerate demanding Ai and
HPC workloads while minimizing TCO
last week we introduced parallel store
our next Generation parallel file system
built on Intel deos
it provides
6.3 X the read throughput performance of
other offerings
and it's deeply integrated with AI and
gke helping accelerate AI workloads like
simulation and Analytics
We are continuing to enhance
storage and performance for AI and
Enterprise workloads running on gke
compared to Amazon EFS
file store has 1.6 extra throughput and
15.7 X the iops
and file store Enterprise provides low
latency High IOP storage for training
models
now we also heard from you we now
support shares as small as 10 gigabytes
and grow all the way up to 100 terabytes
so you can right size for cost and
performance
Salesforce is a really great example of
this
they simplified and scaled terabytes of
data on file store in gke to enable
conversational AI to improve customer
service this is such a great Testament
coming from a company that's centered on
customer success
when I speak with customers
one of the biggest barriers to migration
that I've heard about has been around
multi-protocol support SMB NFS
we are taking our NetApp partnership to
a whole new level with a new fully
managed first party file storage service
and now
like open text you can run and modernize
Mission critical Enterprise workloads
like sap and VMware on Google Cloud
without any refactoring all while
optimizing costs
foreign
We Believe products should be secured by
Design
and secure by default
last year we were the first and we are
still the only leading public Cloud to
offer a generally available managed
backup for GK solution for modern
workloads
it protects your pod configurations and
data and it protects you from threats
like ransomware
and your data is recoverable even if
entire projects are deleted
data security startups like cyberhaven
aren't just relying on Google backup and
Recovery to protect business critical
information or to lower costs
they're using it to meet Regulatory
Compliance and to support GK upgrades so
that they can focus fully on business
innovation
but it's not only about modern workloads
Google backup and Recovery can support
all of your major workloads from Google
compute engine to Google Cloud VMware
engine that Mark talked about the
databases and sap
now as you can see from AI data and HBC
to Modern and Enterprise workloads we
have the right performant and
cost-effective storage and data
protection solutions for you
all right
let's talk about networking
as you get ready as you get your data
ready for AI
doing so easily cost effectively and
security can be quite complicated
in addition to the most performance
Storage Solutions you also need the best
network
now Google's Planet scale network is the
backbone that our customers rely on to
modernize and transform their businesses
rapidly
and recently we expanded our Network to
38 regions with many more on the way
we enable you to run
and build your applications in over 200
countries and territories
and with our subsea cables our 187 Pops
that keep growing
we will now leverage our Network to help
you to solve the problems with
cross-cloud connectivity and security
now I've spent over two decades in the
networking industry working very closely
with many many customers
and traditional approaches are just not
keeping up with multi-cloud and hybrid
Workforce requirements
customers are having to build complex
collocations
they're having to manage connectivity
manually across multiple different
clouds
and dealing with different security
stacks
the complexity is daunting
now sure there are some overlay
Solutions in the market but they do not
provide the benefit of a large Global
Network
and some of them actually
force you to change your applications
and services stack or your security
stack you can't bring your own
we want to simplify all of this and make
it easy for you to connect securely
cross-cloud so that you can get the most
out of Google cloud services such as
spanner bigquery and vertex AI
Thomas introduced this yesterday and I'm
excited to introduce to you the cross
Cloud Network
it's a global networking platform that
helps you connect and secure
applications
across clouds
the cross-cloud network enables three
key use cases that enterprises of all
sizes have asked for
how you build applications
deliver applications
and secure applications
in
a hybrid world
first let's dive deeper into how you
build multi-cloud distributed
applications
we are making it easy fast
and secure
I am pleased to share several new
networking and security Innovations in
this space
earlier this year we introduced Cloud
secure web proxy
which helps secure web egress traffic by
providing inspection and helping to
protect and control traffic that's
originating from Google or from outside
of Google
and we also introduced cross-cloud
interconnect
a cloud native
fully managed service that provides 10
or 100 gigabits per second of
connectivity with four other major Cloud
providers
not only that it is generally available
in more than 20 cities and it's backed
by a four nines SLA
now customers like Walmart are already
using class crowd internet interconnect
in production to simplify networking
between Cloud providers and to shorten
time to production reducing overall
costs
and Yahoo
will use cross-cloud interconnect to
easily and securely access spanner and
bigquery to deliver performance and
security to hundreds of millions of
users
I am excited to announce our new
next-gen firewall cloud ngfw
this is a fully distributed cloud-first
firewall jointly developed with Palo
Alto networks that leverages mandient
threat intelligence
and unlike other Cloud firewalls Cloud
ngfw provides in-line threat protection
with 20 x higher threat efficacy and
shift left network security posture
controls
and with network security network
service integration manager
you can easily integrate your own
partner ngsw of choice without any
customer changes
no network changes required and you can
easily bring in Partners like checkpoint
Cisco Fortinet Palo Alto networks with
more coming soon
McKesson is leveraging cloud ngfw to
simplify the network architecture and to
gain granular access control and enforce
Advanced policies
this helps improve their overall
security posture and lower operational
costs
with cross-cloud network customers can
accelerate the delivery of
internet-facing applications across
hybrid and multi-cloud with our Global
front end
and this consists of our Global load
balancer our content delivery Network
and Cloud armor for DDOS protection
Cloud armor provides ml-powered web
application firewalls which has helped
prevent some of the largest DDOS attacks
on the planet
and there's actually a great broadcom
Cloud armor demo that you can see at the
Showcase later today
we are announcing service extensions
for our Global load balancers which
provides programmability
so you can configure additional security
monitoring and logging services to
support your unique application needs
with just a few lines of code
or you can simply tap into our rich and
growing partner ecosystem
with familiar solutions from Partners
like traceable and human security
replit
is excited to use service extensions for
data plane programmability on load
balancers to customize their back-end
selection algorithm helping their
customers deploy AI applications
and share chat is India's leading short
video platform with merge that has over
a hundred million monthly active users
with Google's Global front end they are
able to deliver the performance and user
experience they need to expand rapidly
while reducing TCO
finally
let's talk about the hybrid Workforce
as applications move to the cloud and
the workforce returns to a hybrid model
customers find themselves managing
multiple individual disjoint security
stacks and this is firewalls all the way
to Security Service edges
not only is this risky and complex but
it also requires compromises to
Performance security control and creates
operational overhead
with cross-cloud network
you have a choice of security service
edge and sdun providers while leveraging
our Global Planet scale Network
and this can help lower latency by up to
35 percent
I am proud to announce a new partnership
with broadcom semantic and Palo Alto
networks bringing you an integrated SSC
solution for your remote users and
Branch offices
what cross-cloud network enables is
truly incredible
but don't take it from me let's hear
directly from Ken Kirchoff senior
director of networking from Priceline
it's priceline's goal to make the
moments that matter for our customers
it's very important for us to be able to
serve customers with a great website and
provide them with the best experience no
matter where they are we launched our
first application running on Virtual
machines four years later we have all of
our infrastructure running on Google
Cloud modern stock in kubernetes with 12
Factor patterns and we're consuming many
Google managed services including
databases analytics Ai and ml it's been
a complete transformation we also use
Google's worldwide networking so that we
can provide them with deals and
inventory for flights hotels and rental
cars
by having cross-cloud networking we can
take the pieces of our company and the
services our company and run them where
they're best suited and think of them as
a whole product rather than separate
pieces with Google cross Cloud Network
what we expect to gain is the ability to
morph our connectivity to other clouds
data centers and partner companies
without having to be bought into a
specific decision and stuck with it so
we're very happy to partner with Google
Cloud to be able to go into the future
with them
what an amazing story
it's been great to work with Ken and his
team and they really helped us shape the
roadmap as well as you saw
cross-cloud Network offers an open
secure and optimized platform
that is designed to help you accelerate
your business
by enabling you to very easily access
Google services
and securely from the cloud
now
we understand
not all workloads can move to the cloud
and this is why we built Google
distributed cloud or GDC
if there are regulations that require a
private Cloud deployment in your own
Data Center
and perhaps it even needs to be fully
air gapped GDC has you covered
if it is an edge deployment in a store
with limited connectivity or it has a
low slows link speed
we have the right form factor for that
and sometimes there's just so much data
that you need to process it first before
sending it to the cloud and we have the
services you need to support that
Google distributed cloud is a
purpose-built full stack solution and it
consists of hardware and software that
extends our infrastructure to the edge
and into your data centers
it is built for Ain data workloads which
enables organizations to run select
vertex AI services and manage databases
we offer flexible deployment options
both in terms of Hardware form factors
and operational models where Google or a
partner can operate
and because an open strategy is core to
Google we have built GDC with an open
ecosystem enabling you to accelerate
application development I'm really proud
to see how excited customers and
partners are about Google distributed
cloud and all of the Innovation that
they are driving let's hear from some of
them now
really elegant solution for us
it becomes much easier for companies now
to dream of an edge solution that they
can deploy at their locations
we deploy it in our own data centers as
a first step into cloudification for our
Network elements allows us to manage the
terabyte of data a day coming off the
network Telemetry devices between 26
different countries
we are going further to modernize
applications in a fully air gapped
secure and Sovereign environment
csip develops secure digital
Technologies for the Singapore
government
csid looks to collaborate with Google on
their distributed Cloud Technologies so
that we can type on Google's deep
expertise in cloud and AI while keeping
our data secure in the now highly
regulated environment it gives them
access to technologies that they're used
to in the public Cloud to move faster in
their digital transformation Journeys
Google distributed Cloud provides you
with the answers to those latency
requirements bandwidth requirements
resiliency requirements taking the
existing kubernetes operators that we've
been running on premise with our
customers and making that available as
part of Google distributed Cloud means
that our customers get a battle-tested
product and it means that we can bring
it to Market with Google much more
quickly and more reliable Google
distributed Cloud gives us a unified
architecture between the data that's
on-prem and the data that's in the
public cloud
thank you it's really great to see the
broad set of ways that we're helping
customers and partners solve problems
with GDC let's take a closer look at how
customers are leveraging gdc's Ai and
data capabilities
GDC helps unlock AI Innovation from Edge
to Data Centers vertex AI on GDC
offers workbench and pre-trained models
for speech translation and optical
character recognition
soon you'll be able to use vertex
prediction in pipelines to automate
custom model deployment and document
translation API for on-demand
translation for Microsoft Office and PDF
documents with the formatting retained
and we have roadmap plans for gpus and
software to enable gen AI model serving
and fine-tuning
with more and more data being produced
at the edge we are making it easier for
you to generate insights by simplifying
database management for all major
engines
we are now offering managed alloy DB
Omni available on GDC in preview it
provides high performance at a fraction
of the cost of Legacy databases it is
also more than 2x faster than standard
postgres for for transactional workloads
and it delivers up to 100 x faster
analytical queries
and with dataproc coming to GDC
customers can run spark at a 54 lower
TCO
finally we're also expanding our
Marketplace offerings on GDC to include
mongodb Enterprise Advanced and
elasticsearch
orange takes one or generates one
petabyte of network collimatory data
every day across 26 countries
with Google distributed cloud and
dataproc orange is heading toward
dynamically managing and analyzing all
of that data right at the edge
but every customer has different
business requirements
Google distributed cloud has an
expanding portfolio of Hardware form
factors to meet your needs whatever they
are
enabling you to do everything from
running deployments of hundreds of racks
in your own data centers to managing
tens of thousands of small appliances
we're introducing a new three node small
form factor server configuration for the
Next Generation retail Edge
I really encourage you to go see GDC in
action at the Hard reverse
Kroger an American Retailer is building
a container-based application platform
that makes it easy and cost effective to
create new and personalized experiences
customer experiences at checkout
they're also using video analytics to
optimize customer experience through
intelligent product placement
shelf inventory and self-checkout
now what makes
GDC really special is how much faster
you can innovate because of our rich and
growing past our ecosystem you can
easily tap into a broad set of familiar
and proven Solutions
I'm really excited to announce a
partnership with sap
which makes GDC the only air gapped
private Cloud infrastructure that will
support their btp platform
from the public Cloud to the edge and to
your data centers
we are making it possible to get the
most out of your data no matter where it
resides
and that brings us to the end of this
session
it's really a privilege to be able to
share the amazing work that googlers are
doing working with you our customers and
partners we covered a lot of brown
let me quickly recap the key takeaways
of this session
workload optimized infrastructure is all
about giving you the advantage and
whether it's AI or data modern workloads
or Enterprise workloads that you're
looking to migrate and modernize
and helping you get the most out of
Google services by making it easy and
secure to connect cross-cloud
we want to enable you to get your Cloud
your way
with Google cloud and Google distributed
cloud
all of this on a platform that is planet
scale
that you can trust
on behalf of our teams we're excited to
develop technology today to help you
discover a new way to Cloud thank you
and enjoy the rest of Google Cloud next